باب الهوى صهيب وكاني شاهدت
قافله تمر في الخلفيه هل بدات فعليا هذه
الشاحنات بالدخول الى مناطق شمال غربي
سوريا
نعم حقيقه وصلت الشاحنات التي تحمل
المساعدات الامميه تستقر الان في ساحه
معبر باب الهوى قبل ان تتحرك الى داخل
محافظه ادلب حيث سيتم تسليمها الى
مستودعات برنامج الاغذيه العالميه هذه
الشاحنات هي عباره عن ست شاحنات لو نطلب
من الزميل المصور ان يحرك الكاميرا
باتجاهها عباره عن ست شاحنات تحمل خيم
طوارئ طبيه ومستلزماتها مثل المولدات
وسائل التدفئه لهذه الخيم
وكما حدثنا الفريق الذي استقبل هذه
المساعدات فهي
تتنقل الى الاماكن يمكنها ان تنتقل الى
الاماكن التي تعرضت لاضرار او بجانب
المستشفيات التي تواجه ضغوطا كبيره هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه
الامميه عباره عن خيم طوارئ طبيه سوف تسلم
بعد قليل اذا الى برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
الى مستودعات برنامج الاغذيه العالميه ومن
مستودع برنامج الاغذيه العالميه الى
المنظمات الشريكه حتى يتم تشغيلها من قبل
المنظمات الطبيه التي تكفل عدد من
المستشفيات في محافظه ادلب حقيقه يعني هذه
المساعدات للوهله الاولى عندما تحدث الينا
الفريق عن طبيعه عملها يعني قلت لو كانت
موجوده في اليوم الاول من الزلزال او في
اليوم الثاني لا كانت خدمه الناس بشكل
كبير لانه في في ذلك اليوم اليوم في ذلك
اليوم ان كان الاول او اليوم الثاني كانت
هناك حاجه ماسه اليها كانت المستشفيات تغص
بالجرحى وكانت وكان الجرحى يتنقلون عبر
المستشفيات الى اكثر من مستشفى في محاوله
للحصول على الخدمه الطبيه لكن الازدحام
الشديد من ذلك وكانت سيارات الاسعاف لا
تستطيع ان تقدم الخدمات
او لا تستطيع ان تستقبل او تستوعب كل عدد
المصابين الذين يجب نقلهم الى المستشفيات
حقيقه هذا يفسر رده الفعل السلبيه هنا لدى
الناس والناشطين في محافظه ادلب الذين
ينتقدون الامم المتحده رفعوا اعلام الامم
المتحده بشكل مقلوب في احد مواقع الدمار
يوم امس وكتبوا على الجدران المدمره لقد
متنا شكرا لخذلانكم حقيقه يعني بعد هذه
الايام عندما تصل مثل هذه المساعدات نشعر
باهميتها البالغه لو كانت قد وصلت في
وقتها المناسب لكن بطبيعه الحال هي دخلت
وبعد قليل سوف تنتقل الى الجانب السوري
ربما او الى الاراضي السوريه ربما سوف
تتحرك ارى العمال يحزون
حتى يقوموا
بتحريكها كذلك وفي الجانب الاخر من هذا من
هذه الساحه تقف سيارات
الشاحنات التجاريه والتي استانف عملها
اليوم هذه الشاحنات التجاريه تحمل المواد
التجاريه من الجانب التركي وتدخل الى
محافظه ادلب لا شك انها مهمه ايضا لان
هناك كان الحديث عن ارتفاع بعض الاسعار
وعن فقد بعض المواد اليوم استانفت الحركه
التجاريه وسوف تدخل الى الاسواق في محافظه
ادلب مجددا وهو اول يوم تحركت الان
الشاحنه الاولى
باتجاه
محافظه ادلب الشاحنه التي تحمل خيم
الطوارئ الطبيه
والمولدات التي ستقدم الكهرباء لها وكذلك
وسائل التدفئه التي سوف تعمل على تامين
فيها في ظل درجات الحراره
المنخفضه والبرد الشديد التي الذي يشهده
محافظه ادلب التي تشهدوا محافظه ادلب
هذه الشاحنات
دخول هذه الشاحنات المحمله بالخيم الى
الداخل السوري انت تحدثت عن الخذلان
بالفعل هو منسق الامم المتحده للاغاثه قال
باننا خذلنا الشعب السوري في شمال غرب
سوريا وتحدث عن زياده وتيره وسرعه ضروره
سرعه ادخال مزيد من المساعدات هل هذه
المساعدات المجدوله لليوم فقط ام ان هناك
المزيد ربما سيدخل اليوم
نعم بحسب المكتب الطب الاعلامي لمعبر باب
الهوى فان المساعدات التي ستدخل اليوم هي
ست شاحنات وكما نرى ست شاحنات دخلت الان
وهي في هذا اليوم يعني هذا هو هذه هي
المساعدات المجدوله في هذا اليوم لكن هناك
جمعيات اغاثيه تركيه تقوم بادخال بعض
المواد الغذائيه البسيطه التي تقوم
بتوزيعها ايضا على المتضررين والمنكوبين
الذين يعيشون في مراكز اللواء المتوزعه
على محافظه ادلب وعلى ريف حلب الشمالي
كذلك
الشاحنات التجاريه التي تاتي
بالمواد الغذائيه وتنقلها الى الاسواق في
محافظه ادلب هكذا نرى الحركه في هذا
المعبر ايضا صهارج الوقود التي تدخل
باستمرار والتي كانت قد توقفت في الايام
الاولى من الزلزال وهي ايضا مهمه يعني
لابق عجله الحياه في على دورانها في
محافظه ادلب لا شك انها مهمه جدا لا سيما
ان بعض المنظمات التركيه يقوم بادخال ماده
الطحين ايضا نعم سريعا قبل ان اختم معك ما
هي اليه تسليم هذه المساعدات
للمحتاجين اليها في المناطق المنكوبه في
الشمال غرب سوريا
التي كانت متابعه قبل حدوث الزلزال وهذه
الاليه كانت ضمن اليه ايصال المساعدات
التي يقرها مجلس الامن الدولي الامم
المتحده تقوم بادخال المساعدات عبر معبر
باب الهوى وهو المعبر الحدودي الوحيد الذي
يمكن له ان يستقبل هذه المساعدات وفق قرار
مجلس الامن الدولي وبعد ادخالها الى
المعبر يتم نقلها الى المستودعات المنظمات
الدوليه الشريكه او المنظمات المحليه
الشريكه مع الامم المتحده يعني هنا في
محافظه ادلب لا يوجد
منظمات رسميه تابعه للامم المتحده مثل
منظمه يونيسف مثلا وهذا قد يكون مرتبط
باعتبارات سياسيه وقانونيه
لكن يتم تسليم هذه المساعدات الى المنظمات
الشركه لامم المتحده والتي تقوم وفق برامج
تعدها واحصاءات تقوم بها بكل فتره
بتوزيعها على المحتاجين والمتضررين عفوا
على المحتاجين بحسب تنسيق المجالس المحليه
في المدن والبلدات الان نفس الاليه نراها
تتبع في هذا الوقت حيث يقومون بنقل هذه
الاغذيه وهذه المساعدات الدوليه الى
مستودعات المنظمات المحليه الشريكه مع
الامم المتحده والتي تقوم بتسليمها
للمتضررين والمنكوبين المتوزعين على مراكز
الايواء ووفق التنسيق مع المجالس المحليه
في المدن التي تعرضت لاضرار كبيره جراء
الزلزال شكرا لك